[Music]
[Applause]
yes
block shot overnight how much marv in
this quarter has the defense ignited
this golden state team
in transition finding klay thompson
steph with a good look ahead offers the
leading
assist man
as he pulled away iguodala with a steal
throws it up but klay thompson throws it
down
beautiful
yes
oh the bench is up everyone is up here
yeah very nice
strong move
see that you'd like to have seen pretend
it look this is a big game between two
teams
here's curry 4-3
backpack thompson
[Applause]
a little action going on
but right
there splash brother the splash family
harden shoots for three out of three
green puts into the front court
gets it to thompson for three
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it might be really appropriate
for nba history he got it
14 trees in a game
has never been done
until tonight
[Applause]
i love what he did he didn't stop for a
jump shot
he took it all the way to the rack
and rebounded his own miss he did not
expect this from clay but he was closely
guarded by jackson so he went by him
a little bit of contact there but the
officials are letting the players decide
who wins
what a play by clay thompson
the presence of mine to stay with it
and shoot it without coming down
booker is crafty
skilled and clay blocked his
[Applause]
a block on one end and 94 feet later
back door
keeps on going and